I decided to do example number two. First off,
we request the page and start receiving the HTML.
We start parsing it immediately and building the DOM.
We come across two style sheets. Style.css and print.css
with a media query for print. We aren't printing,
so print.css isn't a part of the critical rendering
path. We only have to send out a request
for style.css. And then we continue parsing the DOM.
We run into two script tags at the end of
the body. One for app.js and another for analytics.js. analytics.js
is async, so it's not a part of the critical
rendering path. We fire off a request for app.js and
halt building the DOM while we wait for CSS to
arrive and the CSSOM to be built. Now that we
have the CSSOM, the job script engine is unblocked, so
we can run app.js, finish building the DOM and then render
the page. That wasn't to bad.